Smurfs up y'all this is Tara just saw
and Cody also just saw two as well Smurf
Olli
we just lost Merce three yes and it was
Smurf and awesome we did not see source
one and two go ahead smash that thumbs
down yeah it's like we did light I will
also say this you shouldn't have an
opinion on this movie unless you've read
the original Belgian comics list rooms
so come at me I don't know what I mean
you just said the means that I'm very
into it
Belgium is a country in Europe yeah
jean-claude van damme is from there who
I just adored this movie for what it was
we realized that this was made for us
specifically uh we are adults we are
adults I am NOT a child but I do still
get bullied by them regularly
oh just facts it's a science
yeah so we're just gonna give our you
know like our impressions as who we are
so you guys can have opinions also we
can't like we live in a world where
everybody's different
just like the Smurfs oh that was really
nice it was surprisingly fun okay the
movie starts off and we go to 3d showing
because that was in our time zone of
when we could go and the 3d was awful it
was just like a little off so everything
was crazy blurry it was actually clearer
if you took your glasses off I left my
goggles on and closed one eye bad news
no because it was a little better if you
close one eye with the glasses maybe
that was the same thing to have the
glasses off just read yeah that's kind
of how 3d works well now I know okay I
figured it out eventually go to 40
minutes into the film oh yeah yeah like
yeah around there I walked up and I was
like hey Can we maybe change it and he
was like yeah for sure it's Ben he goes
like literally changes it immediately I
was like all right camera was so
emboldened by the strong feminist
overtones of The Smurfs movie that she
finally just went out and took care of
it which I mean to be fair the only
people that could take care of it were
one of us or the one family that was
also in the theater because we were the
only people there who knew this would be
so fun after it didn't look like mush
anymore one thing that was really great
about the movie right off the bat was
that the casting
is fantastic not only do they have
really awesome actors but they just did
a really good job of casting them
everybody fits really well yeah I
especially like standout people was
Rainn Wilson who I am obsessed with
Gargamel a casting didn't feel like that
was a little weird with Michelle
Rodriguez she plays the tough Smurfs and
she's always playing a tough character
and I really enjoy her I think she's
amazing it's kind of rude saying like
such a tough smart man a little too
tough okay everyone a lot of inborn
prejudices against murders apparently I
loved what Jack Sprat McBrayer is a
dopey Smurf or the clumpy humor uh no
baby boy uh yeah I like it and I like
Danny koteas doc Smurf and then this
brainy Smurf but I thought Danny Pudi
was a perfect casting for brainy Smurf I
thought he was a lot of fun and then I
really enjoyed when we got to the lot
Smurf Village I really like Eat Pray
Love summer and Kimmy Schmidt Smurf they
were my favorite Kimmy Schmidt Smurf was
amazing Jamie's read the Commissioner is
a visionary so 3d was off and it took me
a second to get really into it but
honestly I was not expecting to like
glass as much I genuine laugh yeah I
laughed a lot uh and I haven't I haven't
laughed in a while especially especially
um especially with the movies we've been
seeing for this show lately uh I didn't
know if I could enjoy film again the
whole thing was just fun and interesting
like that's all I guess kind of all I
can really say is like I came in I came
in with really low expectations but I'm
when in any situation I'm always open
and hopeful that I will be proven wrong
or that it'll be better because who
wants to sit for an hour and a half
through something terrible like I'm
actively going to try to enjoy the movie
if I'm given a sliver of a chance to is
easy to get me on your side like it is
not hard for me to enjoy anything and I
really enjoyed that yeah I mean we
laughed I cried I got that the s I went
on an emotional roller coaster
I wrote down does the animal sidekick
for my favorite part of the movie yes
they had a so that was a really cool
thing too that I wasn't expecting they
did a good job you know like for kids
for fun kids movie of like world
building like building out past mirth
village they had all these really cool
animals they had all of these really
cool things like they have business
river that turns into a Mario Kart
racetrack basically the bunny has like
horse sounds and it glows in the dark
yeah the glow bunnies and they named him
Bucky which I liked as a nice reference
to Captain Bucky O'Hare it was it was a
very obvious captain Bucky O'Hare
Records and I appreciated that definite
reference they were making I totally got
that did I die
dragonflies who had um like fire breath
fire rest they were dragon cool right it
was super cute just got that I literally
just now got that the dragonflies but
you got the Bucky records I wasn't
matter this is my favorite note of
course Cody's biggest laugh was when the
cat pulled out opera it was a great
moment I left so I had to stop myself
from laughing it was like it was Emma
Watson snowball face laughter you know I
think about come to you know that that
would be his biggest love it was great
to like okay super adorable he like
could draw your mom's looking through
binoculars Thank You Assad opera glasses
I got but also like where did he get the
glasses like we're the other pants yes I
love the relationship with Gargamel and
the cat and also the bird yes don't like
an eagle condors saying I don't yeah you
refer you it is a different name which
is so funny when Smurfs would you be oh
man
I don't my problem is like I feel like I
feel like I'm just brainy Smurf but uh
maybe witty four-legged obscure
references for sure what's right for GB
I don't camera
people call me Smurf all the time
because of my hair okay so you don't
feel fair
what if what if you lean into it you go
with hair flip Smurf oh I don't know I
think if I was a smurf I would probably
just be the cat
well then can I change my middle bird
I'm the bird you're the cat
there we go yeah it was a really good
high five I was Allah did not the out of
the part that high five was as good as
the movie go ahead and smash that thumbs
down button for that high five people
what kind of smirk would you be comment
below
hahahahahaha
the first two were way more magical than
I thought they were I thought they were
just tiny blue people but apparently
they have inherent magical powers I know
nothing about Smurfs so well if you
didn't read the original Belgian comic
Nationals I will move to that I've not
presented my favorite ancillary Smurfs
uh would be stripper cop Smurf it's a
very good hahaha
never customer best murder bessemer he
wins best Murph I don't know where he
just surprises yet they have a Mikey
real super gun yeah they have a huge
smurfin party at the end with
choreography of course and yeah if you
do and there's a stripper customer and
he's great he's solid I wanna know who
plays him I don't think they gave him a
voice actor could you doesn't say
anything but I hope I wish they would
have and I would like to retro actively
play him if they could just add me on
the IMDB I wish the two turns because
they're kind of two turns I wish that
they'd been slightly less obvious but
it's a kids movie so it's like we're
again adults so we're gonna probably see
that a little more then a child would
help yeah wait well I mean I would hope
the children are smart I say that in
about 98% of the reaction videos that I
do for this channel is less no but I was
expecting actually I did write that down
as I guess I said one of the things I
thought about Tamara was she's not going
it's not gonna be what she expected and
it's going to be different than what she
thought listen you got what you paid for
with camera you know what's gonna happen
is it and that I don't know what's gonna
happen but if there was way better than
I what I was expecting
which is the best go into a film also
like half of the movie we couldn't even
see it and it was still a good outcome
yes no complaint I'll cosign everything
all-that signed sealed delivered I'm
yours I'm not saying just ruin the movie
obviously but you know we're here to
talk about our impression
the movies whether how much of the cat
was understood by Gargamel is unclear
and again children's movie I don't
really care but if we're addressing it
yeah I care little bit bothered me
slightly this happens actually a lot in
animation with animals and humans at
certain times it was clear that Gargamel
like could understand him as if he was
speaking English and then at other times
when it served the plot better he it was
just meowing and Gargamel's like quiet
you I'm trying to do stuff over here so
that was just a weird thing that ruined
the movie entirely for me does this tie
into the first two because I know the
first time of Neil Patrick Harris
no that's trolls know is that Smurfs I
believe he was Care Bears never driven
My Little Pony this did have a weird
Care Bear ending uh-huh anyway Smurfette
ending is a very Care Bear type ending I
kept screaming Care Bear stare in my
head fightin like well we didn't see the
anime Smurf
so smash that dislike button our key
it's very naughty smart I would also be
snarky Smurf I multitude Smurfs yeah we
are not just one type of tomorrow right
and I like that that was the next day in
the lesson you don't have to just be one
thing final thoughts I thought it was
super fun super cute genuine laughs
loves the cat good thank you guys so
much for watching we will see you next
week like a smurf in a shell